翻訳: Mika Ikeda
校正: Hiroko Kawano
私が8年前に出会った
子どもの話をさせてください
私が出会った時 彼女は8歳でした
彼女のお母さんは病気で
彼女の面倒を見ることができませんでした
だからといって 助けを求められる
状況でもなかったんです
お父さんは 彼女がまだお母さんの
おなかの中にいる時に いなくなっていました
家はたくさんのゴミが積み重なって
地層のようになっていて
ゴミ屋敷のような状況でした
そして ゴミ以外のものが あまりなく
電気やガスや水道がよく止まって
彼女はそのために
お風呂に入ることも難しく
その臭いのために
友達からいじめられていました
「人がすごく怖い
私の居場所なんてどこにもない」
彼女はよく言っていました
そんな彼女が 初めて
自分が一人じゃないかもと思って
ちょっとだけ自分のことを話せたのが
学校の担任の先生でした
それまでは 彼女は全く
大人のことを信用していませんでした
それはそうなんです
だって 大人は 彼女が
嘘をついた時とか
暴力を振るった時しか
彼女の方を見ようとしなかったんですから
その先生は 彼女が心を開いていくまで
ずっと彼女のことを信じて
あたたかく見守っていました
「うちに帰るのが怖いんです」
彼女は初めてその先生に伝えました
「あの時ね 私は初めて
『あーちょっとだけ
人を信じてもいいのかもな』
『ずっと一人だと思っていたけど
もしかしたら一人じゃないのかもしれない』
そんな風に思ったんだよ」
彼女は こう教えてくれました
こうやって彼女は
私の元にやって来ました
彼女だけでなく
貧困とか 虐待とか
いろんな状況で
生きることすら難しい子どもたちが
たくさんいます
彼女は —
そしてこういった子どもたちは
はたして
運が悪かっただけなんでしょうか？
子供の育ちって
「運」だけで片付けられるほど
ちっぽけなものなんでしょうか？
みなさんはどう思いますか？
ところで私はよくちっちゃい頃
ドキュメンタリーの番組を家族と見ていました
ある日 父と一緒に
小学生の頃なんですけど
番組を見ていたら
海外の危機の話が映ったんですね
「ねえ お父さん かわいそうだね」
私は父に言いました
「そうだね お父さんもそう思うよ」
そして 父はこう続けました
「みんな 同じ一人の人間なのにね
何でこんなことが起こっているんだろう？
この状況って どうしたら
変えられるんだろう？」
私はさっぱりわからなくて
自分なりに考えたり
学んだりするようになりました
けれどちっちゃい頃は
テレビの向こう側のことは
やっぱりちょっと他人事で
そしてちょっと遠い世界の出来事でした
医者になって
父が言っていたようなことが
実は私たちの身近なこのコミュニティでも
起こっていることに気づきました
もしかしたらみなさんも
先ほどの女の子だけでなく
普通に 身近に こんな危機が
起こっていることを
お気づきではないでしょうか？
子どもたちのこの危機は
何を意味しているんでしょう？
これは 子どもたちが今いる
この社会システムが
もう機能しきれなくなっていることを
意味しています
そして その社会システムを作っているのは
そう 私たち大人なんです
子どもたちの周りにある様々なことを
親だけに委ねたり
誰かのせいにだけしたり
それではもう間に合わなくなっています
「一人の子どもを育てるには
一つの村が必要だ」
こんなことわざがあります
そもそも 人は生物学的に
共同繁殖の生き物で
親と子だけでは育てるようには
なっていません
そこには
たくさんの眼差しが必要です
先ほどの女の子にとっても
それは同じでした
彼女は里親さんのもとで
育つようになりました
里親さんは彼女を信じて
「あなたは とっても とっても
大切な人なんだよ」と言い続けました
そんな中 少しずつ 少しずつ
彼女はなくなっていた感情を
知っていきました
そして 里親さんを通して出会った
色々な大人から
色々な表現方法を 自分を表現する方法を
学んでいきました
そんな中でも
彼女がはまったのは絵でした
絵を通して
彼女は世界を広げていきました
最近見せてくれた絵が
とってもおもしろかったんです
風船を持った顔のない人の絵でした
「どんな絵なの？」私が聞くと
彼女がこう答えました
「あのさ 最近思ってることがあるんだよね」
「なんか みんな
自分たちが見えてるものは
信じられるけど
見えてないものって
信じられなくなってるような気がするんだ
もしさ 私たちが
見えてるものだけを信じられて
見えてないものを
全く信じられなくなったら
私たちに残るのは
不安だけなんじゃないか
そんな風に思ってるんだよね
それでね
この風船はその不安を表していて
でね この絵は
気づいたら手元には不安しか残ってなくて
その不安に
必死にしがみついてる人の絵なんだよ」
笑いながら彼女は言っていました
よく 社会を見ている子です
彼女はたくさんの人たち[と]の
出会いの中で
何度も何度も
人を信じることを諦めながらも
それでも自分を信じようと
誰かを信じようと
未来に希望を持って生きています
最近 彼女から連絡がありました
「今 看護師になろうと思ってるの
この前色々考えてたんだけど
あのさぁ
先生と出会ったあの時は
私はバットを振り回したりとか
自分を傷つけたりとか
そんな方法でしか
自分を守れなかったんだよね
確かにそんな方法も
自分を守る方法の一つなんだけど
もっともっと
優しい守り方があるんだよ
そんなことを伝えていきたいな」
私は 彼女の力とか可能性とか
それでも未来を信じようとするその力を
心から尊敬しています
そして 彼女の周りにいた人たちも
彼女を信じてきた人たちも
彼女を信じてきた自分を信じた人たちも
よくこんなことを聞かれます
「そっか じゃあ あなた達は
子どもたちを支援の対象としているんですね」
私はこう答えます
「いいえ
子どもたちは支援の対象ではありません
私たちは 子どもたちと一緒に
チームとして社会を作っているんです」
確かに子どもたちには
守られる権利があり
そして 守られるべき存在です
この「守る」っていうのは
何なんでしょう？
私は 子どもを
社会を構成する一人の人として尊重し
そしてそのことこそが 「守る」ことに
繋がるんじゃないかと信じています
例えばみなさんが
「あなたにとって とってもとっても
良い環境を用意したわよ」と言われて
確かにその環境はその人にとっては
都合良い環境なんだけど
みなさんにとっては
かなり微妙な環境だったらどうしますか？
私たちは 子どもたちに
一方的に何かをするのではなくて
例えば 一緒にご飯を食べるとか
アートとかスポーツを楽しむとか
そんなことを通して
子どもたちと一緒に何かをしたり
子どもたちが自分たちで何かをしたり
そんなことを通して
子どもたちと地域の人たちと
色んなコミュニティを作っています
妊娠して高校を中退した17歳の女の子
彼女はコミュニティの中で
親のような人と一緒に
子育てをしながら 今 高卒認定を受けて
新たなチャレンジをしようとしています
家ではなかなか勉強するのも
育つのも難しかった７歳の男の子
彼は彼に伴走してくれている
そんな人と一緒に
今 自分が好きなことを見つけて
学びを楽しんでいます
たくさんの人が
子どもたちに関わってきました
一人の人として尊重される
信頼がある 愛情がある —
そんな関係性は連鎖し
循環していきます
そんな生態系をいろんな人と一緒に作っていく
チャレンジを今しています
世の中には そしてこの地球には
たくさんの問題が
複雑に絡み合って存在しています
私たちが作ってきた問題です
子どもの幸せを願いながらも
私は 私たちは
この問題を
子どもたちに残していくかもしれません
それを考えた時
私たちがするべきことは
大人中心のこの社会に当てはまるように
子どもたちを育てるのではなく
子どもを一人の対等なパートナーとして尊重し
子どもの世界から見えるその世界を尊重し
そして子どもたちと一緒に社会システムを
デザインし 作っていくことなんです
私たち大人が勇気を持って
一歩踏み出したら
それが社会に 子どもたちに連鎖します
「あなたは未来のある
大切な一人の人なんだよ」
そんな風に子どもたちに伝えられる社会を
みなさん一緒に作っていきませんか？
ありがとうございました
(拍手)